how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel to cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and today we got to talk about the
Wanda vision series now recently it was
revealed that the one division series is
going to resume production starting in
July now this is great news because
hopefully it means that the one division
series will still come out this year
which is great because everybody is
dying to see it especially after these
new reports that we got today and based
off of everything that we're hearing it
seems very likely that Muffy Stowe and
Doctor Doom are going to be set up in
the Wanda vision series two of the
biggest baddest villains to ever come
from Marvel Comics are coming to the MCU
in a story that's going to be quite
incredible so let's dive into these new
reports but if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things relating to the MCU and so you
can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a Deadpool Funko pop all
you got to do is subscribe but like the
video and leave a comment down below so
to start this all off we're going to
talk about the dark hold and mephesto
and then we're going to talk about
Doctor Doom and bring it all together
the one division show really is going to
be a pivotal moment for the MCU
introducing new characters and not to
mention it is going to tie in and lead
up to Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness so really big things coming
from this show so back in April we got a
leak from Roger Ward L Roger Ward L is
the Twitter account that leaked all the
insanely accurate information about
Avengers in game all of which ended up
being 100% true well in April he tweeted
this return of the dark Holt will be
fundamental for upcoming one division
Captain Britain and ghost writer and
Doctor Strange two events of both the
show and movie will prepare the ground
for dr. Doom's debut and it certainly
will
along with mephesto who should be coming
in the actual wan division series both
will be set up in one division the
Darkhold
is an insanely powerful book of heavy
duty spells it's also known as the book
of sins or the book of spells
it's an ancient book of spells and
unspeakable power and this book is made
of dark matter from the Hell dimension
if you're an avid watcher of agents of
shield you definitely recognize this
book although I am almost
100% sure that this is not going to tie
into agents of shield whatsoever Kevin
Feige pretty much said that none of the
shows are really connected to the MCU
but here's where it gets really
interesting along with the release of
the one division series in December
Marvel Comics is planning on releasing a
wonda vision comic event called dark
hold and as Marvel describes it it's
going to be a one-shot comic event
focusing on Scarlet Witch Doctor Doom
and their magical ties to an ancient
book of spells known in Marvel lore as
the dark hold so Marvel is coming out
with this comic right as the Wan
division series releases seemingly
confirming that the dark hold is going
to play a pretty big role in Wan
division and it's even tying in Doctor
Doom which we'll talk about in just a
bit but again where is the dark hold
created it's created by dark matter in
the Hell dimension and who runs the Hell
dimension mephesto and here's why
mephesto is almost definitely appearing
in the 1 division series
besides mephesto is connection to the
dark hold which is basically confirmed
he has a major tie-in to Wanda's kids
her twin boys Wiccan and speed and his
tie-in is that they're basically his
children in the comics wanda has kids
but she creates her kids and she doesn't
create them out of nothing
when she created her kids she
accidentally created them out of the
fragments of mephesto soul originally
thought to be the fragments of master
pandemonium it's revealed that they are
in fact mephesto Spragg ments and what
does he do well he comes back and he
reabsorbs Wanda's children into himself
and obviously for very very good purpose
wanda freaks out and that's where Agatha
Harkness comes into play it's pretty
much all but confirmed that Kathryn Hahn
is going to be playing Agatha Harkness
in the one the vision series Marvel
hasn't come out and said this is who
she's playing yet but we have leaked
photos that show her dressed up as a
witch which is what she is in the comics
she hopes Wanda harness and grow her
powers she also helps look after
Franklin Richards the son of Sue Storm
and Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four
but that's a video for another day but
in the comics when mephesto comes and
takes Wanda's kids Agatha Harkness
erases them from Wanda's memory she does
this because
nothing else could seemingly help her so
she makes it as to where she never even
had them but in Avengers disassembled
when she finds out that Agatha erased
them from her memory she basically goes
insane and that leads us to the House of
M storyline which is practically what
the one division series is based off of
Wanda creates a new reality one in which
her sons are alive also at one point her
brother Quicksilver dies and then she
brings him back to life now this is
seemingly what is going to happen in the
one division series it's confirmed that
her twin boys are going to be in the
show and thanks to a leaked audition
tape we know that Quicksilver is going
to make a return as well so as you can
see it's all lined up for the one
division series we've seen already in
the quick little teaser that gave us for
the one division series that Wanda is
going to create multiple different
realities vision will be alive she'll
have kids and seemingly her brother's
going to be alive as well Agatha
Harkness is going to be in the show but
how does she get her kids that's where
the dark hold and mephesto come into
play Wanda could have gotten her hands
on the dark hold somehow whether that be
through Agatha Harkness or another way
and I think that in this book she finds
a spell that gives her a way to create
her kids because vision isn't a human he
can't give her kids so she uses a spell
from the dark hold but the dark hold is
from the hell realm and the MCU it could
be possible that mephesto created that
book so when she used the spell to
create the kids she could inadvertently
use shards of mephesto soul to create
them and eventually he is going to come
for her kids and this is where her
reality will start to break
she lost vision and Avengers infinity
war she lost her brother and now she
lost her kids and probably the reality
that was created for her and that's
where a GIF the Harkness will create a
reality to keep Wanda sane and then to
top it all off Evan Peters was spotted
on the set of the Wanda vision series
and it is widely believed that he is
going to be plain mephesto and based off
of what we know it seems like that is
going to be the case as mephesto fits
perfectly here and he is a major part of
the story of Wanda's kids in the comics
and then we have the setup for Doctor
Doom who has a big connection to the
dark hold but especially a big
connection to mephesto and this is how
he could be set up and possibly
introduced
and Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness now I've already mentioned that
the Darkhold comic event that Marvel is
going to release with the one division
series is specifically going to be about
Wanda and dr. Doom's connection to the
dark hold so right away we're getting a
little bit of a teaser of what's to come
as it is and then we had Roger Ward L
state that dr. doom is going to be set
up by the dark holt but here's how he
connects to mephesto like Victor Von
Doom his mother Cynthia Von Doom was
learned in the magical arts and she was
born into a Romanian clan in Latveria
here in order to protect her son her
husband and her village she makes a deal
with mephesto he grants her even more
power to deal with the threats but she
ends up dying and according to the deal
that she made with mephesto he ends up
taking and torturing her soul now dr.
doom would eventually go on to get in
contact with his mother and he would
eventually go on to challenge mephesto
for his mother soul every time that the
barriers between the worlds were thin
however no matter how many times he
challenged him he would fail and get
defeated every time that is until one of
the times that he went into the realm he
brought dr. strange together dr. strange
and dr. doom began to fight their way
through the realm until they reach
mephesto once they get there dr. doom
offers his soul and dr. strange a soul
in exchange for his mother's soul
however his mother refuses dr. doom and
dr. strange were now trapped by Mephisto
however dr. strange was given a device
by dr. doom to break himself free and
they continued to battle until mephesto
accidentally lets out doctor dooms
mother's soul and they're able to escape
with her she doesn't fully escape back
to the real world but she escapes out of
the realm that mephesto was in and her
soul is no longer tortured so mephesto
coming into the MCU and being introduced
and the Wanda vision series could easily
set up the introduction for dr. doom who
we know is going to be coming Kevin
Feige has already named dropped the
Fantastic Four and right with the
Fantastic Four is dr. doom and doom is
said to be one of the next big bads of
the MCU along with Galactus and it seems
like the description for the new
Darkhold comic is setting that up it
says for hundreds of years scholars and
heroes alike have searched for the
complete text of the Darkhold aka the
book of the Damned
by the Elder Gods athon now one of the
greatest sorcerers in the multiverse has
found it and chiffon has found him to
save them all the Scarlet Witch must
gather the world's greatest heroes and
unleash their inner darkness well it
seems like the dark hold is definitely
going to be a part of the Wanda vision
series and we know that dr. doom is
going to be entering the MCU and it
sounds like the way that he is going to
become the big bad is by obtaining the
dark hold so it seems like Wanda vision
is going to be setting up an extremely
powerful villain mofesto and I wouldn't
be surprised if he comes in to Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness as
it's said to be a horror film and as far
as horror villains go mephesto was
pretty horrifying and this is how Doctor
Doom could tie into the Doctor Strange
storyline seeking the help of Doctor
Strange to retrieve his mother from
mephesto as far as horror is concerned
going to hell to basically fight the
devil is pretty good but let me know
what you all think about this would you
like mephesto to be a villain and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and in the 1
division series and would you like him
to pave the way for Doctor Doom let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof